welcome bill burns I'm good how are you
you look thin dude oh yeah thank you
nice yeah I've been you know I got a
nutritionist really why I've wanted to
learn I'm [ __ ] hate going to the gym
so I just was like what am I doing wrong
you know so then I went on the Internet
as I go I'll learn about nutrition on
the internet and that's like trying
that's like listening to Democrats and
Republicans thank you good eggs a bet
and I was just like why don't I get
somebody that actually knows if to
through all of this [ __ ] and what do you
think um they just I don't know it's
just a lot of it's boring [ __ ] I mean I
don't know they could I just had you
know what it is I don't that I've
retained it as much as I have all the
recipes so I can show so I do like
smoothies and [ __ ] for like breakfasts
and stuff and did they really fill you
up like everything that I eat now not
now cuz I've been on the road I've been
eating bad but like when I eat I cheat
once in a while too that I eat makes me
feel energized but then I'm hungry
quickly after that yeah cuz I'm fueling
my body as opposed to poisoning it so I
see how [ __ ] Hollywood am I came in
URI you sorry now I'm talking about my
diet your nutrition tell you about my
cause my charity my startup that has my
name on it
yeah it's somehow helping unfortunate
people yeah I've watched those uh like
the food documentaries on Netflix and at
first it seemed like a good idea I was
like oh yeah I can't eat that anymore
oh yeah I guess corn is bad cuz it's in
everything again but then they literally
have a documentary about every single
food yeah
yeah being bad for you there's no
possible way to discern which one's
[ __ ] which one you should be doing
yep and the food Lobby is strong from
what I've heard yeah Sam when did you
start doing the whole this old house
look he just built a deck or something
my plan number two pencil behind you
here kind of like looking and measuring
yeah
do you like the beard we hate the beard
now I like it I like it a lot
yeah give me gives you a rugged look
that's why yeah that's why it looks like
there's no hassles I can build things
balances out the Gabe Kaplan
but you see that like this old house is
the thing a man would do yeah that's the
first time somebody has said like oh you
look like you do manly things that's
probably because I have facial hair now
maybe do you know like you you know how
to build some [ __ ] right exactly
I don't all right yeah it doesn't matter
yeah he just no one doesn't know that
mm-hmm but just walking down the street
people gonna look at that builder yeah
this is a guy who can help me even so
more before you look like you created an
app focused on how much we hate the
facial hair we the whole staff what's
wrong with it
thank you better thank you well I'm
trying to get bill to help you
you can just say looks good Josie
that's so qualified like you could just
say that looks good if you say that
looks better than its it's a direct
reference to me believe you're not a
good-looking guy another word yes well
you come yourself up the better your
radio that's [ __ ] Jason master people
have said they said the beard is is
makeup for men men men men will grow
beards the way women use makeup to cover
up their horrible faces damn okay there
you go which is something that I think
other people who grow beards are told
that's what I think things are said and
then they're retweeted and then they
become truth yeah how's your company man
we had Ted Alexandro here yesterday
promoting this special oh yeah yeah
we've been we signed a deal with Comedy
Central to produce three one-hour of
four one-hour specials the first one's
gonna be Paul verses that comes out [ __ ]
on November and November 2nd and then
we're gonna do gonna do one with Ian
Edwards
Jessica Kirsten and we're figuring out
somebody else right so these are all
[ __ ] people that you know Ted
Alexandro working with all these people
that comics know are great yeah but they
don't uh they don't like like right now
he's a Sam has a great industry look all
he needs is just have the hoodie you
have the very the alt look that was big
I don't think it's in anymore
she's not no no no you got you got a
dick so that's like nine strikes right
there
behind yourself and say something about
Hillary right then I think maybe they
can get you a holding deal it's a weird
time Jim how are you handling this
comedy climate are you sick of that
[ __ ] question yeah yeah they're
really talking about that with mark
before you came in marching up marks
heaven it marks having a tough time I'm
nervous
dad don't be to drive the bus right
through it that's the point but it's you
know you never know know you take to
process and burden of proof and you
throw that out the [ __ ] window right
need to give it to a bunch of [ __ ]
lunatics who think that they're so
goddamn right I mean they're insane
they're [ __ ] and saying there's so
many people on Twitter that I follow
like ironically there's I got the big
stories want to hear what the [ __ ]
they're saying yeah how do you spin this
one on the Kavanagh one was somebody
tweeted I lost male friends this week
and and then people were like consoling
this person like something happened to
her it's like this isn't about you this
this is this poor woman's story right
and you're hijacking it and people are
consoling you cuz you're watching
something you just hear at home you gave
yourself [ __ ] jury duty and you're
gonna sit here and watch this thing that
you don't have a [ __ ] vote on and get
yourself all worked up it's it's some of
the best entertainment they love it they
love waiting angry and you know what I
never got is the norm hate and they go
well he was never funny like what are
you kidding I never liked norm like what
he's maybe one of the best of all time
yeah no one had to go to an apology tour
for having an opinion yeah he didn't
even he didn't do anything he just
didn't have the opinion that they wanted
and he had to basically yeah yeah he has
to apologize to 15 percent of the
[ __ ] population and The Tonight Show
cancelled him and they said respect for
our viewers like what I know people are
crying and these things who is crying
tonight oh no yeah it makes no sense and
it's all because he did it in the first
interview on us to stop pointing that's
triggering me I'm sorry okay
I want an apology from you I didn't mean
to be aggressive I did some things that
I know you can't see the Sam is pointing
of this day I didn't understand I now
understand that my behavior right I
didn't I didn't look at it through the
lens the current Clint lens of this
climb that's right that's
very tone-deaf of you it is it was in
village trigger oh sorry yeah sorry
about that yes didn't promise er but yet
the because he did it on the beginning
of a press tour cuz obviously he had to
keep going on the press to her and so
the rest of it he wasn't even promoting
the Netflix show anymore he was just
promoting the fact that he was
apologizing for the first interview on
the tour ah you know it saved norm the
view the view was nice to him they all
like yeah they were great to her it's
the best joy was great to him Whoopie as
a you know something Whoopie goes back
and forth of the comics but I think she
was great to him they were all pretty
nice to norm and I'm like I think that
just kind of stopped the bleeding but it
was also great because he stopped doing
interviews and it just went away because
people got distracted by the next thing
to be asked about yeah now everyone's
off the hook with this [ __ ] Saudi
Arabia story there's no one getting any
[ __ ] now everyone's kind of played what
happened there the actual murder
I'd even missed this it happens
I was asking Jim who books this club and
I accidentally killed him fingers off
one by one well there's audio of them
cutting this guy's fingers they say
there's audio I believe it I believe the
Turner's girl was monitoring the embassy
there's things through his Apple watch
but it's [ __ ] but I'm like that all
the conspiracy stuff that we've talked
about in the past this is a [ __ ]
juicy one dude how can you how could you
[ __ ] do that to another human being
listen to them scream in agony and then
you can continue there's a there's a
there was a quote and the thing that we
were saying that somebody said they
heard the audio and that the guy who was
cutting off the fingers and stuff said
something to the effect of I always wear
my headphones when I do this and like
Patrick Bateman in American Psycho put
his Walkman on or whatever and started
playing music through his headphones so
he didn't have to hear the screaming the
human being so you know we deserve
what's whatever whatever the end of this
is yeah we're just awful so you're
willing even though you're not a human
being that would cut fingers off the
fact that your species does that you'd
be like you know what that's a wrap
we did it yeah we did it to ourselves I
didn't do it personally all right so I
please do that like now what am I going
to do as a person to continue to make
sure that the
happen am I gonna get involved you know
or am I gonna go buy a New York Post and
get a bacon egg and cheese sandwich
that's it yeah second one yeah yeah
second one yeah it's the same thing
we're all gonna do
that's something I've been messing
around through my Aquin people the way
they'll talk about you know white male
privilege and all that type of stuff is
like I can't wait for it to level out
and I want to see how you behave when
you're up in the hill and you're in the
hot tub you're gonna get out of the hot
tub you're gonna you're not gonna do a
bump model you're gonna get out of the
hot tub and walk down the hill and go
help somebody change a flat and their
[ __ ] tire it's just it's not human
nature and they're they're they're
equated it to sex and race and that what
it really is is just human beings are an
incredibly self-absorbed and selfish so
if you're in a position of that of
privilege you everyone's going to behave
you know you're privileged I do when I
walk and I know that was wonderful of
you to announce you're checking your
privilege yet giving up on what it is
you're woke thank you can't break balls
anymore because somebody's gonna take it
seriously right they're gonna somehow I
don't know all of a sudden you said
something about baby seals and you have
to like apologize because there's that
straight triggered somebody it wasn't
that you said that but if your vagina
you can statutory rape somebody and it
goes away in like [ __ ] six minutes
would they end then male priviledge the
whole time oh that's what it was so it's
not that big of a deal yeah it is it
doesn't count right it doesn't count
right you saying the baby seal thing
that woman would now I get it yeah now I
get it she was raped by a baby and you
should have known that before you said
yeah cuz it's been a confusing time I
want to make sure that I'm on the right
side of woke yeah we have to be on the
right side of history bill yes we did
and then I always worry what if we're on
the wrong side of history and the right
side it's become this this speak right
it's like all of this language did not
[ __ ] exist now and I was like this is
crazy [ __ ] code like you're in a cult
yeah yeah you're gonna be found out if
you know like I don't want the [ __ ] that
means and if he's just walking around my
favorite thing is how like literally
think it's like 80% of people after [ __ ]
goes down everybody's just sort of quiet
and then you just saw a pair off with
friends being like dude
murmuring yeah
but no one's saying it out loud
everyone's just murmuring yeah how could
people act like you know when they reach
a level of success that somebody like a
bill burr has reached that you can't
have conversations like this anymore
like how have you survived
how have ice in this current climb this
current I wasn't sure if you were
talking about the the previous client
future climate know the current climate
as we head towards the future climate
towards the huge club well you know I've
I've you know I've readjusted navigate
it is fun right
however cuz I'm not saying anything
wrong I'm not like saying anything like
mean-spirited right and when people like
try to like they do all that gotcha [ __ ]
and you just I just throw it back at him
they'll be like so what do you be like
promoting a [ __ ] movie in the big so
what do you think what Lily come on I I
don't know what do you think about it oh
that's terrifying seems to be on your
mind
you kid what did you put I'm trying to
promote a movie you're trying to [ __ ] it
in my career here you [ __ ] like five
lines in the movie can I keep my
l-shaped couch you [ __ ] people will
never acknowledge I know what you're
doing you're only asking me about this
because you don't care you want your
tray we're hoping I'm gonna say
something stupid Xin so you can get a
bunch of hit and what does that say
about the victims right here exploiting
the victims hoping I'm gonna say
something stupid you know what I'm
offended I'm offended by your question
oh no and I feel like in this current
climate we triggered bill burr this is
the to ask about Louisville burgers bill
Burke is you know terrible gonna be the
first white guy that gets triggered ask
me about my trust fund I felt that was
personal but is that interesting you
identify as a white guy huh
that's what you identify as hey I don't
think there's really any choice
once I shave my head I could curly I
could maybe he said I had some sort of
some flavor next and
somebody in there I don't know although
I don't know you saying that you don't
have any choice as to what you identify
as that's gonna trigger people okay you
know what I mean people do have the
choice you know my favorite thing is
gender-neutral bathrooms like it's this
groundbreaking concept it's like
everyone chill dude everybody in your
apartment you have a gender-neutral
bathroom but because there's no
silhouette and there's nothing written
underneath it it's like this big like
you know all the bathrooms in your house
like those are all gender thing if I'm
gonna take a [ __ ] that's gonna end up in
a river and choke out a [ __ ] octopus
or whatever I need a silhouette drawn of
what I identify as it's right in order
for me to relieve myself it's right well
otherwise pedophiles are gonna come in
and molest people you know I don't I
don't know where that came from but
that's what they say personal like I
just I just I'm sorry I'm sorry
like I've had experiences and I just
feel like I shouldn't have I shouldn't
have you know I don't feel safe in here
anymore this is a safe space I might
have been exercising privilege with that
last statement and I yes
you know I as I learned from Bill I've
actually re-examined my question and I I
take that back and I'm actually moved to
public service all right because I'm the
one who's offended there's no way I can
ever forgive you and I don't feel you
should ever be able to come back here
right and sit in that chair and even if
you do forgive him we won't I did that I
don't like that I didn't have the choice
as to whether I was gonna sit across
from you or not how you should have here
you should have said told me where
everyone was gonna be seated seated
before I got here I came in here I'm
gonna ask you how you felt about not
told you asked right right and there's
not enough minorities in here oh my god
you're right we're [ __ ]
I mean I just got fired all of us are
done it doesn't matter as many public
apologies as you want yeah but it wasn't
enough the stink of privilege is oozing
under the door that's right Yeah right
he didn't he didn't apologize enough
I've pulled back from all of it mm-hmm I
try to avoid all of those questions and
I as I [ __ ] sit here joking about it
for 20 minutes I just watch like me TV
yeah I watch old gumshoe shows now I
don't
like is going on I just had given into
being old and I've just when people come
up and say I'm offended or I was
triggered or whatever I'll just go okay
I'll try and work on that Perry Mason
Sunset Strip is my show Peter Gunn
nobody gets killed quicker than on an
episode of Peter Gunn it was only like
[ __ ] 22 minutes long so at least
somebody like sticks their head into a
room and somebody chops it off and he's
done what is 77 now what's that Sunset
Strip it actually kind of started off as
far as I understand it started off the
the whole gumshoe like show everybody
ripped like Peter Gunn was because of
that show so it started Efrem Zimbalist
jr. there was another guy Edie Byrne he
played this guy kooky and he became like
this teen idol sensation he's actually a
really really good actor and all that
swells ebin I know ed burns name well
the brothers McMullen Edie burn but this
guy was like eat like with two DS oh
okay it's just you know one of these
shows and it's like it's it's cool cuz
there's murders and stuff like that but
it's also that corny 50s thing like one
of the characters he's always betting on
horses so he always makes jokes about a
horse and in case you didn't get it that
it was a joke about a horse they
actually play a trumpet that goes
watching this is like 3:00 in the
morning I just like I get it you had to
do the horse [ __ ] thing with the
trumpet but that's your escape yeah this
bet your little vacation from no it's
fun you go back and you watch an old la
it's not as crowded right there's still
the four seasons you know there's a
climate change although the first report
I guess was from back then I don't know
yeah so so there's that that's probably
why I watched like Shark Tank and Law &
Order and those marathons of just
nothingness we just mindless mindlessly
sit there and go episode after episode
after episode Shark Tank if you watch it
for just how crooked the world is and
how much your ego can spin out of
control is a fun show to watch just
watching them [ __ ] these people over
and acting like one of my favorite ones
is a YouTube clip of this guy who just
turns down everybody's offer because he
knows the value of his company and they
actually I guess it went on to make a
bunch of money and they get so [ __ ]
upset yeah but he says no to them that
they just resort to like name Carl
like arrogance your blahblah I I just
know what my company's worth and you
haven't brought it to me yet yeah I'm
not gonna do that how much were they off
by well they were offering like two and
a half I don't I don't get half the
[ __ ] jargon in there so it was uh I
was Ed Burns sorry but whatever whatever
his company was according to the YouTube
comments right is now with like 14 did
14 million in business or something like
that and I want those people to be right
because you know whenever I watch that
show this is just like back in the day
like when you would come in when the
industry was holding all the cards right
you would go in there with your hat in
hand hey here's my great idea like great
we're gonna own it
we're gonna pay you great money the
first time around and then that's gonna
be cut in half and then we're gonna
start sending you checks for [ __ ]
seven dollars and 11 cents mmm while we
we you know yeah we're hang [ __ ] and
infinity pools I was watching one like a
couple of nights ago where the woman
comes in asking for like whatever it is
150 grand for 20% of my company and the
offer ends up being like I'll give you
175 grand but I'm gonna need 75% of the
company and like the woman's got these
tears in her eyes because she's put her
whole life into this company and she
says something to the effect of like you
know what owning a big piece of
something small might not be as good as
owning a small piece of something big
with Mark Cuban I'll take it and you're
just like 25,000 more Shiva 55% more for
life kind of company it was like a
product or whatever it was one of those
invention things just bail because you
get the exposure just from being on the
show that's what they were saying that
guy did yeah or like E or like a mr.
wonder the ball guy mr. wonderful he's
the best one he's the best cuz he always
makes these deals that are so
complicated that nobody's standing
there's gonna figure him out and he goes
like it's alone and when you pay it back
I won't own any of the company but I
want one dollar for each item sold in
perpetuity how much were the items
selling for whatever it was I don't know
but they don't know I thought was 75
okay but they don't know what perpetuate
like they like all this stuff perpetuity
what [ __ ] you forever
yeah and they're gonna bad word you know
what okay we do need the cash flow so
we'll do it and now they gotta give this
guy a dollar for every item sold for the
rest nice yeah I hate that I hate then
again if it's if it's regular people
getting [ __ ] out of there right yeah
and that's why I'm out and how they sit
up there like that you know they got the
whole world figured out there is these
tremendous you know being [ __ ] you
guys are why sitting up there like you
the Mount Rushmore of something no you
made reboot of good but now because the
show has been on so long well he must
know what he's talking about he's the
guy from shark tank I know he's not
known from anything was what he actually
did right right he build a company now
he's started a spin around in the chairs
like they do on the music show I'm on
the voice like that's my invention no no
not that one when they sit there
listening to the notes as it floats by
their artistic ears mm-hmm they spin
around well that's how you know it's
real because they're not picking it
based on the aesthetic this is about the
music I need to hear why can't they look
at them I don't get it because they need
to look away because people shouldn't be
judged by how they look Jimmy can't
prove it they should be judged by what
they're bringing to the table this is
some of the problem with people like you
in positions of power yeah judging
people how they look you're not wrong
but with your genetics and the gifts
that you were given how many free drinks
you think she'll see yeah and then all
like the I've seen the new trend is like
the like beautiful women that have like
millions of Instagram followers just
because they post swimsuit you know
photos and stuff like every three weeks
or something have to post something
about the the stress that they went
through like when they were like I've
been judged on my appearance so many
times we're feeling ugly I was when I
was young I'm [ __ ] Club right and
it's like what your hope is this is just
that you're hot I know I was called ugly
and I am exactly I was accurately called
ugly okay
my comeback was fair enough Touche show
your eyes work those it's Graham but
models I follow many it's weird the guys
who like them why do you have to click
just enjoy it
oh yeah there's not attention I guess I
don't know there's the hope that they
gonna pull you out of their depression
with their sculpted ass they're gonna
back it into your life when the sun's
gonna start shining on you they're gonna
scroll through their likes their 10,000
lights and finite one yeah that was a
nice guy you liked me it's hope it's
like the stripper the guy the stripper
guy was like she likes me well go people
go crazy online like any of those
pictures if you start reading the
comments guys will be leaving comments
like grown men that are like oh oh I
love you're such a beautiful spirit and
oh it's another great photo but I really
love you - I love your personality we
should so what I'm special I'm special
it's just it's it's mental illness it's
I see through that piece of thong
between your butt cheeks to the to the
you're the sole the person that you are
that's right I saw through your anus
like a telescope I looked up through
your [ __ ] and saw your heart is the
window to the soul beautiful but models
they promote each other they're generous
they promote each other you gotta check
out my girl Kiki but you know how the
group does them you know that's clicky
you know there are but models that have
been cast away from the other but model
so you know I think they've always been
more like open than titty models models
it very because they're not in right now
right like to the seventies yeah 90s it
kind of want with those big balloon tits
that right we used to have what the
[ __ ] almost like we had like
bloodshot eyes it was just jump the
shark
there was like no way to go with this
and then it became about now it's about
the ass yeah you know so they're all
support me I do like that though not not
a giant giant but I do like a nice fat
the best
yeah but the answers have gotten so
ridiculous and big like now it's like
they're it's the same thing that
happened with fake yes the fake ass is
the fast yeah
I felt one you can know when you feel
thank you yeah you can feel it it feels
it's a harder it's soft but it's almost
like member how Stretch Armstrong used
to feel or like the danoi yeah that's
what it feels like no I just love it
doesn't move with the legs like a lunch
box a lunch box you want to [ __ ] right
Yeah right it's just it's just I know it
was uh what the hell was I think was in
a gym or something like that as someone
recently but I saw one out here surprise
me there's a lot of them in LA yeah more
so more so more so in like you know uh
Miami like Dallas in Miami in Orange
County is where I see the most
extracurricular so that we may get on
the road now now that you kind of been
into every like sports stadium you've
seen all the games now it's like I need
to I need to monitor the fake asses in
each city no I just noticed wha like
when I was in Dallas was just every
bartender just had these giant and they
were like teardrop shaped titties I was
like what is in the water on here and
like someone's out the NAM and these are
most of those are fake they just do so
many they're really good at them in
Dallas and Dallas yeah and then Arizona
to Phoenix women huge yeah yeah yeah so
Orange County was like that was the one
where the guys was crazy like they had
the remember Bruce Jenner I mean I got
sure I don't know disappear I've seen it
from it it was good well they they had
like the eye lift that [ __ ] going on
like the yeah where everything just
looks like yeah you were like in a wind
tunnel or something like that and I
remember because my wife watches all
those Real Housewives I used to think
that like okay they just took an extreme
version this is not an accurate
portrayal of it and you go to Orange
County it's not obviously not everybody
but it is it's just it's a noticeable
enough segment or maybe cuz I watched
the show with her III noticed when I
walked by was playing the The Improv and
Irvine you know I was walking between
shows I was just walking through the
mall or whatever and I just I saw like
three or four guys that just had that
that Bruce Jenner [ __ ] yank back kind
of thing going on there so I don't know
I don't know why you would do like I
think you just you look so much better
if you just kind of roll with your
genetics yeah it is what it is it's
days even right you know what I mean
where it's just kind of like Novi always
places on the face you can't do that's
like Jane Fonda looks [ __ ] amazing
yeah yeah but then there's always gonna
be that one spot we don't know like
whether it's right around the eyes or
the neck there's always something
horrifying that age is exactly like it
should so 90% of the face looks good but
then there's that one part really oh
[ __ ] that's an old lady the lips are
tough
the literary talk give it away lose
moisture oh [ __ ] she's one of the
Andrews Sisters
but that mean it's the same thing when
you see guys to get like hair plugs for
everyone that goes really well you see a
guy like I said guy walking down the
street the other day and he had buzzed
his hair but you could tell the whole
front was plugs and it was just don't
you love that I love a horror show of
hair plugs yeah because it depends it
was really well really really really
[ __ ] about getting but not I think vacu
so first we used to get the big smiley
face Yeah right
now they can just sort of vacuum the
[ __ ] out and put it in and then it takes
for some people and it doesn't for
others but they're trying to say like
someone was telling my podcast because
I'm always like threatening to do it as
a joke you know and they said that like
that stem-cell [ __ ] if you shoot in the
top of your head so I was joking because
I'm gonna do this Eastern European tour
coming up in January that I was gonna go
over there and find some Transylvanian
doctor over there to [ __ ] shoot it
and I was going to come back with the
redhead version of like Farrah Fawcett
hair dress it wasn't that he wasn't old
enough for it to be bad you probably
just didn't want to spend a bunch of
money yeah no it's it's themselves do it
too they they have those they should
they do those facials where they called
vampire facials I don't know if that
stem cells but they shoot like you're
they do something with your blood then
they put your blood back in I think it's
a lot of whatever the [ __ ] is in
platelets and then they shoot it into
your face and oh yeah young people's
blood some sort of fetus involved no
yeah they just mush a fetus and they
melt it down and shooting your face but
no it's your own blood you know when
they make avocado you know that bowl
you got to drink it and shake hands with
the devil do they do it into your face
they're supposed to be very good for
like wrinkles and moisture or whatever
but it's legit I gotta say you've kind
of been reverse aging man I mean if I
had some of the pictures of you from
back in the day like yeah you were
hideous yeah you look like a beat cop
[Laughter]
come shoot Jimmy then you start doing
the pull-up Emily you know a wrinkle on
your face
yeah my face is held up okay and there's
other things should have made my face
wrinkle free right yeah Caligula was
right at work either
no that helps it not smoking I think
quitting smoking helped a lot too in
2001 yeah oh I forgot you smoked I
smoked for 17 years yeah and I quit when
you quit that helps a lot
see guys have smoked with a 50 or go
mm-hmm yeah I mean the benefit to never
being attractive is that when you start
to fall apart it's not like it's a
heartbreak yeah no one no one says hey
what happened to Sam exactly like I fell
off yeah it doesn't doesn't matter
that's the thing about all those
beautiful people say that that's what
like the ugliest people in the world
would say [ __ ] like oh my god you see
someone so what the [ __ ] happened to her
it's like the same thing they happen to
you you just you just fell off a curb
right yeah nobody hit the pavement yeah
I mean it's the better guy it gets you
like later later in life is where it
starts to reap the rewards but no matter
how mediocre you are you know where you
look you always feel it like I look at
myself like [ __ ] you but way back
whatever it is you still like you know
it's still coming if you're a psychotic
you eat like a tiny candy bar and you
lose your gut like oh my god I'm getting
fat again well but you know it's just
the way you look at yourself he holds
himself to a higher standard I don't
feel it's good for you who know I did to
shame him he is shaming me I don't like
it i Jim has had food issues they are
shared as far back as I have known and
it's so brave the way he judges himself
after a three musketeer
[Laughter]
the perfect candy bar form two three
guys dress up his [ __ ] sailors Three
Musketeers you do don't
very tasty nougat you like it he likes
the newbies he's nuts so what are you
Wow you'd be surprised what do you are
you what are you doing in town you're
doing garden boating yeah then I'm gonna
be at Madison Square Garden on November
7th with Paul virzi and Joe bartnick
who's your warning Joe Barnack is a
Pittsburgh guy via San Francisco
completely unfiltered first time I son
was at the punch line in San Francisco
and he just just watching him in front
of that crowd it was just like he'd do a
joke they'd pull back and he'd the tag
was even harder and after three jokes
the crowd was just like I guess he's not
stopping and I just want a ride it was
one of my favorite the first time I ever
saw a comic moments that I've had and
he's just you know he's always writing
new stuff and just him and virzi both
always kill in front of me so I've
always joked I don't bring any cupcakes
on the road you know what I mean like
that those people bring a weak act
writing that makes them look good these
guys both kill it and they keep me on my
toes I did enjoy the promo video you put
out announcing that you're gonna be a
Madison Square Garden because you were
just pointing up at the lack of
championship banners really weren't
worrying about endearing yourself to the
New York on it's nobody it's East Coast
you can break balls like this you know
actually you can break balls like that
pretty much around the country you
wouldn't think the way in this climate
but you can't people like it's like if
somebody breaks my balls like swears
like literally like warms my heart now
it's I almost get like nostalgia right
like did you make fun of my shirt all
right guys [ __ ] great do more do more
you know there is something fun about
being attacked yeah I people who are
funny it's fun to be attacked by people
who you like and who attacks well yeah
people that you like in that it's funny
you know yeah bus station but it shows
you're on the same level you know like
you wouldn't call a [ __ ] person
[ __ ] no you call mark
[Laughter]
no but yeah being attacked by someone
who's good at dissecting it's fun it is
fun it can be really fun it can be awful
- you can go home and you start looking
at all these little things like I never
I never noticed that I never know you
got that before I did
oh no that was like clean they knew that
about me I thought I was hiding them
right [ __ ] right amount of amount of
shirts that went to the Salvation Army
after a night at the [ __ ] cellar I
won't be wearing this anymore when Bobby
came in with security guard pants for
you then he came in but they had the
stripe down the side like a security
guard how long was the pounding for the
entire night until he left it was it was
it was a beating it was a beating all
right
but that's when it's really good yeah
when their beatings that are so bad you
can just fondly reflect remember the day
that he walked in with those pants and
it's like everybody who was there goes
oh that was a class there's something
fun about like when you're being
attacked by people again who know you
and who are accurate and who are funny
at it and you're just covering up and
taking a [ __ ] beat Heath and Bobby's
fun were the ones that invented you know
at some point just tapping out and
running out of the club and I remember
thinking the first time one of them did
just leave back tomorrow ah
have you ever thought that it was like
okay I think he's gonna start hanging
out I think he's one of us and you start
going and you realize I go no this
person is is not one of us at all this
is a sensitive guy somebody who's upset
about this oh yeah I can't name names
but right I mean and somebody said
something about somebody else about this
female comic and the look of sadness and
hope the way she looked at me like I
wasn't gonna laugh to her reaction was
even funnier and I [ __ ] died laughing
and I died yeah it crushed her people
got crushed down there I mean I get to
but I mean you just had just from you
laughing them you had to be strong
enough to come back Sheena's like she
never came back but I'm right I remember
she was disappointed I had a couple of
those like people were disappointed in
because they were just straight-up
[ __ ] mean I was inconsistent
I'd be like a swell guy and then I would
just say
figure me out so people had hope with me
you know what I mean so I just I
definitely disappointed some people
because you just didn't have that middle
ground you just went right to the very
worst no me and Bobby Kelly didn't know
how to play the game like I learned how
to play the game through Patrice Voss
Norton and Keith where there was a light
heartedness to it the way it was done
and as far as I don't speak for Bobby
but as far as like when we exchange
notes like like it was mean right like
you were trying to hurt somebody so we
would start mmm Bobby like that was his
tag everybody would be joking joking
joking and he would just say something
completely [ __ ] up and would just be
totally silent he just go Bob Kelly so I
feel like both of us had to learn kind
of how to how to do that so and Bob
would go to violence sometimes he
wouldn't hit you but he will yeah woman
I left Bob would threaten violence and
you could tell Bob was getting ready to
physically fight Bob gets upset Bob gets
yeah we have what we got into one-timer
talk about handler but we you know it'll
hold your money and like somebody I said
in paper-money will go away and the
[ __ ] screaming match we got into on
43rd Street that we had to walk away
because he was gonna get physical with
me Bob over that Bob holds resentment
some stupid ox